how do you curse so much
for a guy who doesn't need to because i
only believe in authenticity it's how i
talk when i think about do i care about
my employees it feels more in my brain
and my heart and my soul do i give a
[ __ ] about my employees more than do i
care about my employees that's from my
brain and heart to my mouth but i feel
like there are people who will never
consume my content are you kidding me
i am willing to deal with the
ramifications of me being my full self
do you curse at home a ton in front of
your kids yep i'm just not devastated to
go into my fourth grade teacher and mrs
thompson's like you have a real problem
what's that mrs thompson your daughter
curses i just don't see that as a real
problem me and mrs thompson just don't
see the world the same way i am the
byproduct of mrs thompson telling me my
whole life that i would be a failure mrs
thompson thought that a d in science was
going to be my downfall just like she
thinks saying [ __ ] is her downfall i
don't agree